JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
Thanks everyone
who's joining us on
live stream and who
is able to come in person.
I'm Joel Kalmanowicz.
I'm the host, and I'm looking
up at the camera there.
I'm a Googler.
I'm a product manager, and
I'm an aspiring parent.
That means that maybe
sometime next year,
if everything goes well,
I'd like to have kids.
And I start early when
I prepare for anything.
So my wife and I
went to this talk
that she found by
these characters
I'm about to introduce, and they
did this talk at [INAUDIBLE]
High School, and it was
all about parenting,
which is not surprising.
It's the whole point.
But it was also
about psychology,
and it was also about
technology-- three
of my favorite things.
And I find one thing that
they usually have in common
is that to the either
uninitiated, unformed,
or just to the aspiring, they
can all be kind of scary.
But what I really liked
was that this is not
a fear-based message.
This is all about
hope and prevention
and looking forward
as to how can
we not only avoid the
pitfalls but, in fact,
raise our kids
higher in the future.
So a quick introduction then.
These are the co-founders
of My Digital Tattoo.
They have some pretty
awesome chops already.
They've talked to a lot
of different people here.
I even had to take
notes on these numbers.
It's been over 14,000 students,
5,000 parents, 400 educators,
and 100 schools in the Bay
Area as well as 800 health care
providers-- all in the
last four years alone.
So they provide education
training in four key sectors
from all of thoss-- schools,
families, corporations
and health care.
They also just presented at
the annual RSA conference,
where captains of industry
were asking questions
about how to deal with their
kids' privacy and security
worries online--
kind of interesting.
So without too much further
ado, Gloria Moskowitz-Sweet,
who's been a social worker,
educator, program developer,
and university
lecturer since '81,
and Erica Pelavin, who's been a
family psychologist for over 20
years.
Please welcome them, and I'm
going pass it over to them.
Thank you very much.
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ SWEET:
Thank you so much.
Joel, thank you for inviting us
here, and thank you for coming.
And we recognize you and
felt you in the audience
because your hand
was up an awful lot,
and there was a tremendous
amount of interest.
So we're delighted to be here.
We have had the privilege now
of working with 14,000-plus
students from all
over California,
and it's their story we
want to share with you.
It's their voices.
There are no textbooks.
Anything that anybody
writes is dated immediately.
It's their voices that have
continued to school us,
and as we have kind of
taken this journey with them
over the past five years,
we have learned so much.
And our goal today is to
teach you and take you
into what we've learned.
So we, as Joel said, we are not
fear-based we really believe
in the power of technology.
We see it being used incredibly,
beautifully, and strongly
and in empowering ways.
So we understand the power.
We watch kids learn.
We watch kids collaborate
with each other.
We watch them feel empowered
in this incredible world,
and we have watched
them do amazing things
around creating a kinder world.
They actually call
it the "kinder net."
But we also recognize
the challenges,
and the challenges are a big.
And we're going to
talk about both,
and we're going to talk
about them without judgment
because it really [INAUDIBLE].
The tool is here to stay.
It's what we do
with it and how we
choose to support our kids in
using it ethically and kindly.
So Erica is going to
do the first half,
and I'm going to
do the second half.
And we'll have
time for questions.
ERICA PELAVIN: I
don't know if I'm
standing in the right place.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Erica, and I'm the mom of
two boys-- one in high school
and one in college.
They are huge gamers.
So I've started
learning about this way
long ago when they started
entering the world of gaming.
But what I've learned from
being a mom the last 20
years of their life, is that all
the skills that I have offline,
being a good parent and
thinking about things, really
translate into
their online world.
And that, oftentimes, we get
fearful and frozen about what
they're doing online, and if
we step back and actually just
think about how we
parent or how we
liked what our
parents did to us,
there's some beautiful
translations.
So we're going to talk
a lot about that today.
I thought I'd start with a
story that can help ground us
in the importance of
what it is to parent
in the age of social
media or parent
in the age of technology.
When my son was in
the fifth grade,
I decided to have a pool party.
I was really excited.
It was back in the time when
I felt like I was the manager.
I got to pick all the
friends that came.
Oh, sorry.
I got to pick all the friends
that came to the party.
I got to decide
what the theme was,
what parents I
wanted to be around.
And I hired a lifeguard, and I
hired a lifeguard particularly
to stay in the deep
end of the pool
because my fifth grader is a
risk taker, and I thought, OK,
something's going to happen
in that deep end of the pool.
So I hired a lifeguard right
in that spot, in the deep end.
In the middle of the
party, I walked in,
and there was a child
drowning in the shallow end
of the pool, right in that
space I think we've all been,
where we can't feel
our feet anymore.
And all of a sudden, we
get that panicked feeling.
And he's slipped
under, and I had
to jump in and save
him and take him out.
And he was OK.
The kids were really
upset about watching.
But when the mom came, I
think I had a real attitude.
I'm sure I did.
I'm like, uh, excuse me, does
your kid know how to swim?
You left them here
with no supervision.
And she said, no, but
my kid is so good.
He never leaves the step.
He never goes anywhere.
He just stays in
that shallow area.
So when she left, Gloria and
I started to talk about it
and process this.
And we realized that
it's similar to life
in the digital age-- that
most of the time, our kids
are in the shallow end
doing beautiful things
and making safe
and good choices.
But every once in a
while, and I think
it's sort of their
job to get curious
and to go a little
deeper or to get pulled
into what's happening in
the deep end of the pool,
and that sometimes they slip
under without even knowing it.
And really what we need
is to be their guides,
to be their teachers, and to
get in the pool with them.
Now I know that I never liked
getting in a bathing suit
or getting into the pool.
But I knew that it
was really important
that I got in there, because you
can't just throw your kid out
there without
learning how to swim.
We're going to have
to hold on to them,
teach them the rules of
the road when they actually
don't mind having us
help them, when they're
interested in being with us.
And then, in my opinion, now,
with high schoolers and kids
in college, is to move away and
become that consultant-- help
them self-regulate and
advocate for themselves.
So when they go
out in the world,
they can do that
without our assistance.
But if we freak them out
so much in the beginning,
we've seen that kids are less
likely to come to their parents
when they feel like
they've made a mistake.
And I think Gloria and
I are real believers
that we want our kids to
make mistakes on our watch,
because then we can help them.
We don't want to have
everything so perfect for them--
snow plow the way
for them-- that they
don't make any mistakes.
It's their job.
So I just want to
put that out there,
that it's a good metaphor to
think about that we want you
there in the pool with them.
No matter what age
they are, the kids
we've talked to
tell us that they
want their parents to
hear what they're saying
and to supervise them.
But we're going to talk a lot
about strategies we've heard
over the last couple years.
Some of them may stick with you.
Others might not be things
that work with your kids.
We kind of want you to think
of it like a big colander,
and we're going to
throw a lot at you.
And some things will
stick, and you'll
say, yeah, I'm
going to try that,
or that might work with my kid.
And other things may not have
anything to do with your kid.
But I think what's
important for Gloria and I
to convey to you is that you
are the expert of your kid.
I always kind of say
find the book that
says what you want it
to say and follow it,
because you know your kid.
You are the expert.
If you see that things are going
poorly, you step in offline.
And what we want
to remind you is
that the same is true online.
So
Kids don't really see an
on- and an offline life.
They just see it as an "is."
They're rarely leaving
their phones behind.
They're usually
attached to them.
And so what we find is that
if your kid is experiencing
trouble offline-- gender
identity, depression,
friendships, sitting
alone at school--
any of those things that
are happening offline,
you can be pretty sure that
it's going to follow them
into their online life.
Now, that's not
necessarily terrible,
because sometimes they're
going into their online life
to look for support or to
help diagnose themselves
or to find something that's
going to make them feel better.
But for us to keep in mind that
if we're worried about our kids
offline, to check
out what that looks
like in their digital space.
The same is true for their
passions and interests.
I've watched my kids
just expand in things
that they're interested in.
They become world experts.
Alex had figured out a way
to apply to all the schools
that had a scholarship
for e-sport gaming.
That certainly
didn't come to me.
He went out there, and
he founded himself.
So our kids are really
taking what they're good at
and getting better on it online.
So I think that's
important to remember.
Gloria and I often get
asked, are our kids
addicted to technology?
And I think kind of
I'm trying to answer
that question for myself.
Am I addicted to technology?
I'm finding it harder and harder
to leave my device behind.
Because we're here
for an hour, I'm
going to give you
our general guiding
principle about whether your
kid is addicted to technology.
And for us, it's the
simple question of,
is it opening up their world,
or is it shutting it down?
So I have one very shy kid,
and it opened up his world.
He tried on behaviors that he
would never have tried offline
and then was able to
practice leadership roles
and take it offline.
He met friends with
similar interests,
and he has virtual
playdates, where
he feels loved and respected.
But we've also seen it where it
can close down people's worlds,
where they get so invested
in finding the next "like"
or feeling relevant, that it
can close down their world
and make things uncomfortable.
So pay attention to that.
Pay attention to
how you're seeing
them use it, because not all
screen time is the same for us.
It really depends on
what they're doing
and how they're using
it and balancing it.
But I do want to remind us--
I think this is so important,
and it seems so simple.
But every time I come back to
this, it's a good reminder.
When we talk with the
kids we work with,
but also with my
own kids, that kids
are kids-- that really
nothing's changed in terms
of teen development,
that they're actually
doing exactly what
they're supposed
to be doing to be these
incredible curious beings when
they start to grow up.
So I want to remind
you that teens
are using social media to do
all the things that they're
supposed to do.
They're socializing with
their peers, like we did.
My mom used to ask me, like, how
come you come back from school
and you're immediately
on the phone?
You know, I had a
cord back then but.
I immediately went to the phone.
And they're doing exactly
what they should be doing.
Most of the kids we
work with actually
tell us that the reason they're
socializing online so much
is because they're so
over-scheduled, that they
need these little bits of time
to connect with their friends.
And I find that so fascinating
because they're telling us,
we need our community.
We need to stay connected, and
we're finding ways to do that.
So they're also trying
on incredible identities.
And Gloria, Mia, and I
just got this Bitmoji app.
Anybody familiar
with it, where you
can make an avatar of yourself?
One of the kids suggested to us.
And you put all
these outfits on.
Have you seen it?
And it can be really
silly and fun.
I think our kids are doing
that, kind of like how
I used to play dress
up or try on new ideas
when I went out to parties.
So our kids are really trying
on new identities as well.
But most of all, what
our kids are doing
is trying to establish
independence.
And part of what I think happens
in this new paradigm, where
we don't know exactly what
the roadmap is to parent,
is we start pulling back and
trying to hover over them.
And their job is to keep
moving away from us.
So if we can do that in a
way where we can stay curious
and they can start to take those
risks and gain independence
and we're not
hovering over them,
I think we're really
giving them the greatest
gift, which is to start
being critical thinkers.
And I will tell you that
when we're in the classroom,
our kids, from ages
fifth grade up,
are going to be the ones that
come up with the solutions.
When we ask them for solutions
about how to manage group texts
or how to manage
their sleep, they
come up with incredible ideas.
So we really need to use
them and harness their power.
But for the most part, I
want to say they're really
using them in incredible ways.
They're using them to
connect, to support.
We've even seen
kids doing causes
for other kids in their school.
They're using it
for school work.
They're collaborating.
They're creating YouTube videos.
I mean, I can't
tell you how excited
a group of fifth graders gets
when we come in to talk to them
and are curious about
what they're doing,
because they're doing
such amazing things.
But at sometimes,
our kids are slipping
under, like in my pool scenario,
and making those mistakes.
And sometimes, as
a parent-- and I'm
sure this was true
for our parents
too-- we keep saying, well,
we told you that already.
Or, come on, I have
to say that again?
We already talked about this.
And they're slipping
under, and I'm
wondering if anybody knows
why they're slipping under?
Why are our kids slipping under?
Why do we have to tell
them so many times?
They're actually
missing something
in this area that
makes it really hard.
We've given them this incredible
tool with incredible power,
both to take care of themselves
and their reputation,
but also to hurt and
harm other people's
reputations and feelings.
And they're kind of
missing something, which
is that their frontal
lobe, which helps them
with that long-term
planning consequences,
isn't fully developed.
And for me, that's a
huge takeaway, that we're
asking them to do something
without literally having what
they need to do it.
So for us, sometimes
we need to talk
with the kids we're talking
about-- what's this going
to affect you like tomorrow?
Or how is this going to
affect you this afternoon?
Because telling a
kid, oh, you know,
if you put that out there,
and 10 years from now,
when you have an
employer looking at it,
they're not going to
like it, is really
kind of hard for someone
whose lobe isn't developed.
And, of course,
with our teenagers,
our middle schoolers,
and our high schoolers,
their emotions are so high.
And those of you that have
kids will know, or go back
to when you were
that age, that you
can be happy and sad and
silly and mad and anxious
and left out in a whole day.
And so when you have a powerful
tool and a bunch of feelings,
we have to really be lending
them our frontal lobe
about how to deal with it.
And that all those feelings are
normal, and they make sense,
and they're easy for us to look
at and say, like, oh, come on,
get over it.
There's no problem.
But to them, they
feel really real.
They change rapidly.
And I always say, if we can
name it, we can tame it.
So instead of just
shutting off the device,
if we can start helping our
kids to say, I felt left out,
or I don't feel
like I measure up,
or my body doesn't
look right, then
we're giving them this
huge service to talk
about what they're experiencing.
I want to talk a little bit
about this evolving landscape.
And Gloria I used to just
call it the digital landscape.
And we realized that
working with kids every day,
that really it evolves as
soon as we know about it,
something new is coming up.
And I think that's probably
why we like this work so much,
because it's constantly
changing, and areas of interest
keep moving.
But I wanted to tell you a
little bit about what we're
seeing in the last
six months or so,
about what's happening
on this digital landscape
for our tweens and teens.
And I think this actually
even relates to us,
as I think about
how I'm starting
to use media more and more.
The first thing we're
seeing is that kids
are trying to stay relevant.
And many of our
kids will tell us
that they're trying
to curate their life,
to make it look a certain
way to their friends
and the people around them.
And I just want to take a minute
to think about how exhausting
that is to have to lead a
curated life-- to have to think
that there are strategic times
that you need to post in order
to stay relevant
or not forgotten.
And that that newsfeed
happens so quickly,
or those texts
come so frequently,
that if you miss
that opportunity,
you're not going to
be noticed and you're
going to be left behind.
Now, this is not true
for all of our kids.
But many of our
kids will tell us
that they will put
a post up, and if it
doesn't get enough likes,
they'll take it down.
They will tell us that they
know their prime posting time--
that I get my most
likes at 8 o'clock.
Or that they feel
upset that they
spent the whole weekend trying
to make it look like they had
a life, and no one
noticed-- so just really
sinking into that
idea that our kids are
having to search
to stay relevant
and how difficult that must be.
So a perfect conversation
with our nieces, our nephews,
our kids, our friends
is to talk about how
we don't want to
define ourselves
based on the number
of likes that we get,
and really going to do
what our parents did,
which is searching underneath
to see what's important
and what we like about our
self, without people needing
to give us the praise for that.
The one on the top is my
son, and I put it up there
because he is a virtual gamer.
And he spends lots of
his time in his room
in multiplayer environments
with people all over the world.
He's joined teams
all over the world.
He has friends all
over the world.
And I don't know if any of
you have this experience,
but if you're on what's
called a virtual hangout-- you
can't say play date once
they leave elementary school.
But when you're on
this virtual hangout,
it's pretty incredible.
It feels like
everybody's in the room.
I think when I started,
I used to think
they're just in parallel play.
How can this be any
kind of interaction?
They're just on their devices.
Now I'm seeing that they're
interacting as a team,
and they're doing
what I see is engaging
in some pro-social games, where
they're learning some pretty
incredible skills about
community guidelines,
about friendships, about how
to stick up for somebody,
about how it feels when someone
trolls or being mean to you,
and that they're actually
doing a lot of the pre-learning
as early as fourth grade
in games like Minecraft.
But most of all--
and that corner right
is our advisory board, which we
go to a lot to look for advice
and to run things by them.
They are socializing
with their friends.
And I think most people
would look at that
and they would say,
they're not socializing.
They're all on their devices.
And they will tell us,
if they looked at it,
that they're all talking to each
other or sharing or having fun.
So a reminder that
our experience
might not be how
they're experiencing,
and to talk about that.
Does anybody remember
this Whack-a-Mole game?
So the thing that--
I can't believe I
kept going back to
Whack-a-Mole as if I
was going to figure it out.
And I always wanted
to get a higher score,
and the thing would
come up and go down,
and we would get frustrated.
And Gloria and I just thought
this was a perfect image
to talk about how it
feels to stay up-to-date
in our kids' lives with
what they're doing online.
And I think as soon
as we figure it out,
they've gone somewhere else.
I mean, that's sort
of what they're
supposed to be doing, right?
If we're at the party,
they're going to leave.
I mean, that's embarrassing.
So I don't think
our job is really
to have to know exactly what
they're doing it all times.
But our job is to
be curious about it,
to see trends that are going
on, and to ask them about what
goes on in each of these sites.
And I put the word
down "code switching"
there because for those
of you, you might even
be doing it yourself,
Because I certainly do.
But most of our
kids will tell us
that they actually have
a whole circle of ways
that they go and
check their media.
Like, they have
their Instagram open.
Then they'll check
their Snapchat.
Then they'll look at reddit.
Then they might do a little
Pinterest board or Wishbone
game, and that they do
this kind of in an order,
and that each one
of those platforms
has their own way of being.
And so that they have
an amazing ability
to code switch
between each of those.
I just want to talk about
the importance of opening up
the dialogue.
And for me, I always say,
be curious, not furious.
Because I think it's so easy
for me to say to my husband,
to my kids, like,
what are you doing?
You're wasting your time.
We should be out and
going and doing something.
Well, that doesn't
really set the tone
for somebody wanting to tell
you about what they're doing.
It sets the tone for you
telling them to go outside,
and then they take
their device and go
with their device outside.
So I'm curious to encourage
you to ask your kids, what are
the apps that people are using?
What do you like about them.
To try it on yourself--
today I tried on a new app.
It was called--
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ
SWEET: musical.ly?
ERICA PELAVIN: No it
wasn't musical.ly.
But musical.ly's another good
example, where we can get on,
and we can do karaoke, and
we can be playful and fun
and really feel what
it feels like to want
to do 10 videos,
instead of just one
and to have a hard
time not wanting
to fix it and make it better.
So the more we
enter their world,
the more I think we get a
sense of what they're doing,
rather than being mad.
So let's take a look at the
apps that we're paying attention
to now.
Our kids have moved
away from Facebook.
Any idea why they moved
away from Facebook?
We're on it, right?
Our grandmas are taking selfies.
Our kids will tell us, though,
that because you're on it,
they'd like to ask
you a favor, which
is to stop posting pictures of
them without their permission.
And I think that's
important because it becomes
part of their digital tattoo.
But we're also asking them to
do that with their friends,
so that the digital
drama decreases.
So kids will tell
us like, I really
don't want that picture of
me in the bath tub nudity
when I'm 12, and it says like,
where have the years gone?
That they really want
you to model and ask them
for permission.
I'm just thinking that
all of these apps,
for me, have good intention.
I don't think any apps are
created to be mean or bad.
What we know is when teens go
anywhere in a large number,
that things get sexual and
that they pushed the envelope.
And so, I guess, I wanted
to talk just briefly
about each of these,
maybe just not
all of them, but about what kids
are finding amazing about them.
But also some of
the things you might
want to start talking about
or thinking about when you're
talking about these apps.
So they are moving away
from Facebook, like we said.
They check birthdays
there, maybe
communication with relatives.
But it's not the space that
they're hanging out in.
I wondered if anybody knew--
let's just pick one of these
up here.
Anybody know Kick?
Yeah, so what do
you know about Kick?
AUDIENCE: It's a messaging app.
ERICA PELAVIN: Yeah, so we love
it that it's a messaging app.
We love it that it's free and
that kids can get to use it.
And what we also
know is that when
you take your kid's phone away
and you think that they're not
going to be texting
anymore, that they're
getting the free Kick app, and
then they're able to use that.
I'm also going to point-- I
got the five minute sign--
that the right is
called Followers+.
What I think is
interesting about that
is that it takes
analytics of how you're
doing with your postings.
I want you to think
about that with your kids
to see did someone
unfriend, did they
not, what's my top
post-- really to talk
about that's really important.
ooVoo is that group chat, where
our kids get to be together
in a group formation.
Any time we're in
a big group, we
run the risk of mean
behavior happening.
Periscope and some of
the other live apps
are a place where we're
seeing a lot of problems
because kids aren't
really thinking
with their frontal lobe, and so
they're exposing things quickly
in the moment and not pulling
back to think about it.
And the only thing I wanted
to say about Instagram
and Snapchat is that
Instagram-- your kids
have two Instagram accounts.
We're pretty sure of it now,
that one is there curated one
for their family, and
one is their real one
that they share
with their friends.
So talk about it.
Same thing about Snapchat-- it's
fun, exciting, really playful.
They don't have to
be picture perfect.
But there's lots
of room for people
to feel left out of
situations, to feel
like things are
happening in live time,
and they're not included.
We've also had this amazing
shift from real name
to anonymous culture.
And it's like our kids
are listening to us.
We asked them to be careful when
you put your name out there.
So they went underground.
So the three that
have come into play--
love you to ask
your kids or nephews
or nieces if they
know them, and how
you see them being
effected-- is the
After School app,
ASKfm and the Burnbook.
So really talking about the
power of anonymous apps,
how we can be a little meaner
behind a screen, how much more
we have to focus on stepping
in someone else's shoes
to be able to really feel
that when we don't see them
on the other side of the screen.
I want to tell you about
this incredible thing
that we keep hearing
about with kids, which
is how much these gurus and
Viners are their friends, how
much they look up to
them, how much they wait
for the next video
to be released,
and how much information
they can give us
to how are kids
doing, to kind of get
a psychological
hold on how they're
doing in the world-- what
they're gravitating to,
what they're interested in.
So I love just asking kids,
who are your favorite YouTubers
or Viners and why?
And you get incredible answers.
The middle one is PewDiePie.
The top is-- I call him the
Mr. Rogers of Minecraft.
His name is Stampylongnose.
There's Jenna Marbles
at the bottom,
and Miranda Sings at the
bottom, and Jenna Marbles
in the middle.
But I want you to
think the same way
you did about asking your
kids about their friends
in elementary school.
I want you to ask them about
the people they're watching.
How did you get
introduced to them?
What's interesting about them?
Hey, let me take a look at it.
Instead of saying oh, I don't
like them, or they're no good,
we actually just talk about what
they're interested in and why,
and sit down.
And we can learn
so much about them.
Our kids tell us that they
want us to supervise them, not
"snoopervise" them--
that they don't
want you to take their
phone away at night
and look at what they're doing.
They want you to go
through it with them
because they're-- creates a
feeling of anxiety if they know
that you're always kind
of overlooking them.
We want to tell you that
we rarely see predators,
and we know parents worry
a lot about predators.
And if your kid is
struggling with issues,
then you may see that.
But for the most
part, the drama's
happening with their friends.
Ask your kids, what's
the digital drama
happening right now in
your squad of friends?
We want to look for openings
for connection and discussion.
So in my life, I
send my kid-- I used
to send him a note to
his lunchbox, I love you.
Now I sent a note to his
inbox or [INAUDIBLE].
And give them an out
of hard situations.
So I'm going to
end with this one
and then hand it over to Gloria.
But I think this feels like
my most important slide, which
is-- and I think Gloria
started with this, which
is I think that the
tool is here to stay
and has incredible power.
But just taking it away,
without having a conversation,
leaves them just wanting
to go underground.
So, for example, in
my house I don't like
single-person shooter games.
And I can say, I don't
like it because I think
it desensitizes you to
violence, or you can say,
I'm worried about your sleep.
Or you can say, I feel like
in those musical.ly videos
you're sexualizing
yourself to get attention.
And so instead of
taking away the app
or taking away the
device, I'm going
to encourage you to
have a conversation,
to be curious, to
enter their world,
to hear what they have to say.
And to kind of think
back on our parents
and when they were
open to knowing
what we were doing
without shutting us down,
it was the time we made
the best connections.
And then we can send our kids
out being self advocates.
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET: It has
been such an incredible gift
for me to work with
Erica and to really look
at what intrigues us so much.
As a psychologist, as a
clinical social worker,
we are really intrigued by
the psychology of technology.
And we want to take
you into this place
that we have been in
for the past five years.
But to do that, I'm
going to ask you all
to go back to middle school.
And I'm just curious
how many of you
would go back to middle
school if you could?
Not a single hand
is going up here.
Very rarely do we
see hands go up here.
Can anyone tell me why
they wouldn't go back?
Like why would you not
go back to middle school?
Puberty, yeah.
Self-consciousness--
like the light is on you,
and everybody's
watching-- absolutely.
So let's go into this right now.
Actually, as you go back, I
want you to remember when.
And in doing that, even if
you're not a parent yet--
I mean, Joel when
you talked about it,
you were thinking about what
it would mean to be a parent.
So the best way to do this is
to think back at this time.
So let's remember one.
How many of you remember doing
a note that looked something
like this?
So we all had a version
of something like this,
and this was very
important to us
as we were defining ourselves.
And the most important
thing was to be liked.
We all wanted to be like.
We wanted everyone
to approve of us.
And it's really no
different, is it?
It is still, do you like me?
And as Erica mentioned, our
kids are complete-- well,
not completely off Facebook,
but getting off of Facebook.
It's about insta-likes,
and it's about evaluating
your self-worth by
the number of likes
and by the number of comments.
And we've had so
many conversations
with kids about this, and
it's been really an eye-opener
for us to have them talk about
what it means to really get
social collateral and social
currency by the number of likes
they get and the number of
comments, and how strategic
they are about that, and how
careful they are about that.
And what we say to
parents is that this
is such an incredibly
important conversation, If you
see your child completely
defining themselves
by those likes.
And, by the way, I'm going talk
about my own kids around this.
When my oldest son would say to
me, in spite of my best self,
at the age of 29, I cannot
stop looking at how many likes
I'm getting on Instagram.
So we all know that pull,
and I want you to imagine
that pool on steroids.
Because for kids, to be
liked in middle school
is what they are all about.
And to us, that
is the discussion
that we want to
have, and we also
want to look at it for
ourselves too, but definitely
look at it with our
kids and appreciate
that this is a time when it's
really, really huge for them.
I want to talk about the
impact of social media
on the adolescent brain.
And as we talk about
this, we're going
to be looking at
generalities, and we're
going to be looking at what
we know about the brain,
and we're also
going to be talking
about what we have learned and
what kids have shared with us
as well.
So we know that our
brains are hardwired
to seek new information.
That is no different.
We literally get a shot of
dopamine, the happy chemical,
in today's world with a text,
with a tweet, with a like,
with the buzz.
We get this surge.
And again, imagine
this in middle school,
because it's far bigger.
It's a much more intense surge.
What our kids are saying to us
is that their texts and tweets
are highly perishable, and
they lose that social value
if they're not
responded to instantly.
This has been an interesting
transition for us
in this field, because
what was five years ago
an acceptable amount
of time-- can anyone
guess what an acceptable
amount of time
might have been about three
years ago to respond to a text?
A day.
What do you think it is now?
AUDIENCE: Two minutes.
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET:
Not even.
For many of our kids,
they talk about wanting
an immediate response.
And if they don't get
an immediate response,
they will think that something
has happened-- like dreadful--
to that person.
They've even said to
us, maybe they're dead.
We've heard kids say that.
Or they think that they've
done something terribly wrong,
and therefore that
person's not responding.
So that response time
has shifted enormously,
and I think it's shifted for
every adult I know as well.
I mean, there's no
question about that.
They also let us know
that the fact that it's
highly perishable makes
this device so incredibly
important 24/7, because
they're not in the know
if they don't have it.
They often will say to us, if
I don't respond to a friend
right away, she's going to
think I'm a really bad friend,
and that means my call is
to be 24/7 and always there.
And that imperative is
incredibly important
to look at because that's
a really tough way to live.
And we see a lot of our
kids-- I would say, well,
it's not just our girls.
It's girls and boys
really struggling
with this issue of
being always on.
Let's continue thinking
about what this biology is,
and let's look at some
of the chemicals that
are going on in the brain.
Dopamine is one of
these key chemicals
that we know about
scientifically,
but we're also hearing about
it a lot from our kids.
Of course, they're not talking
about it in terms of dopamine,
but they are saying it feels
really good to connect.
It makes them feel like
they're really in the know,
and they are really loving
that constant connection.
And we're talking
about brain chemistry
because it's dopamine
that gets stimulated
by tiny bits of new
information, which is
exactly what social media is.
So we can see the pull for this.
And then we're also talking
about oxytocin, which is what's
called the cuddle chemical.
And it releases a feeling
of goodwill and connection.
And that's what the
comments are about.
That's what the likes are about.
And that's what's really
getting highlighted
in the brain of an
adolescent-- And not just
the brain of an adolescent,
all of our brains.
So between dopamine
and between oxytocin,
it's really hard to
stop wanting more.
And we can really see that pull
that our kids are experiencing
and, by the way, that
we're all experiencing.
I mean, I don't
know anybody that
is completely honest
that would say,
I'm feeling the tug
of this as well.
But we know that for our
kids, because of their brain
chemistry, it's more so
than it is for adults.
So that's our
advisory group again.
And with that in mind, with
sort of a very brief look
at brain chemistry,
would you say that kids
are addicted to devices?
And I'm just curious
about a show of hands.
How many of you would say
kids are addicted to devices?
So some hands are going up.
How many of you would say
you're addicted to devices?
I think I am.
You're on the fence--
not quite sure.
So we're going to look at
two ways of looking at this,
and I want to say to you
this is without judgment
at all, as a mom.
I didn't mention earlier I'm
the mom of three young adults,
and they have led me
through this world.
And the work with
all of our kids
have really taught us
so much about this,
and this is what we're
seeing and hearing.
Our kids are saying to us, we're
not addicted to our phones;
we just like each other.
And in an over-scheduled
intense world,
where there's so much
expected of them,
and they have to move so
quickly, those times-- I know.
I remember-- of just space,
where I could ride my bike
and no one was watching me.
And I didn't have
to text my mom.
I can't even imagine
that as an adolescent.
Those days are over.
So what it means to be tethered
to their parent is huge,
and they are missing that.
And they really
don't have that time
to play the way they used to.
So they're using a device
to connect and to play
because that need to connect
is no different than what
any of us had.
What we also have
seen very clearly
is face-to-face conversation
begins where digital ones end
and vice versa-- that
there is no on or off.
It's exactly the same.
It's one world.
And that both really contribute
to that formative development
of identity.
They're both
incredibly important.
So that's one perspective
in looking at this.
And then we're also
seeing another.
We talked about the power, and
we talked about the challenges.
And so I'm going to look at
the challenges right now.
This is a quote from one
our 12th grade students,
"you're not alone when
you're on your phone."
And we're seeing that ability
to be alone really shifting.
And I know when I take a walk,
I very rarely see someone alone
anymore.
I mean, there is
a device going on.
There's a full
conversation happening.
So we are struggling with
what it means to be alone,
and that's an interesting issue
when you think about invention
and new energy often comes
out of that alone time.
And we're seeing
less of that now,
and that's an interesting
thing to ponder on.
So again, this is
our advisory group.
And if we look at them,
we see sort of this
is a very typical
discussion with our kids.
And you see them kind of on
their-- there's a phone there.
There's conversation,
and you see a head down.
And that's not uncommon at all.
And what we are hearing and
what we're seeing from our kids,
and from most people-- and
here's a conversation we had
with one of our kids, quote,
" if a phone is on the table,
I will keep my
conversation light,
knowing I don't have full
attention and that at any
minute someone will
be distracted."
And I think that is a
very, very true issue,
and that has shifted.
That is something
very different.
We didn't hear that
five years ago.
We are seeing that now.
If the phone is on the table,
I will keep that conversation
light, and I'm not
going to go deep
because I know at any minute
I'm going to lose attention.
That was an 11th grade student.
Our kids are learning this new
social norm in middle school.
They're learning it
when they are learning
how to look like they're
paying attention to a lecture,
and their texting
underneath their desk.
They're learning that they can
pull this off and pull it off
really, really well.
So we're watching our kids
feel that this is something
they can absolutely do.
But the question that I
think we have to address
is, are we losing the
complexity of what it
means to be in a conversation?
Because conversations are
complex, and we have to know
and we have to be able to
tolerate that awkward silence
when you're not sure
is it my turn to talk,
or is it their turn to talk?
We have to figure out
where to stand in space,
and am I too close?
Am I too far?
When do I make eye contact?
When do I look down?
This doesn't happen if a
child's looking at a device.
And this personally gives us
concern, because what we know
is that those skills
are still needed.
It doesn't matter
our world is here
to stay-- our world of
media is here to stay.
But those skills
are human skills.
And I think it's
important for us
to all pay attention
to the fact that we
are seeing our kids now
struggling with this
in a really, really big way.
Many of them are telling us
that they would much rather text
than they would
talk, because they
can control the conversation.
And if they're
talking, they've lost
control of the conversation.
And I think that's
an interesting thing
to pay attention to.
Has anyone seen this photograph?
I would imagine
some of you have.
It was a photograph sent to
us by one of our advisors.
It was taken about a year
ago in Redondo Beach.
And we are convinced
that this man is
Googling where to find whales.
And we're sure that he missed
exactly what he needed to see.
And we know that there
was a guy in front
of him taking this picture.
And I had this fantasy of
him screaming, look up!
I mean, just look up!
And the guy never did.
So we are tethered.
And you all-- most of
you-- raised your hands
in terms of your own tethering.
And our kids are very
honest about that.
We're tethered to our devices.
Our kids are tethered
to their friends.
Our kids are tethered in
romantic relationships.
The amount of texts
that go back and forth
can be overwhelming and almost
suffocating to many of them
in late middle school
and high school.
And I want to talk a little
bit about the tethering we're
seeing for parents,
because that's
a really interesting
level of tethering
that has shifted quite a bit.
We are hearing from colleges now
that there's an expectation--
well, they're
seeing that there's
parents and kids are texting
sometimes seven to eight times
a day.
And the texts can take these
very interesting turns.
They can be things like--
and kids are sharing this
with people at college.
Can you geolocate
the library for me?
And you can you
geolocate the bookstore?
And while you're at it, I'd
like you to get my books
and get them immediately,
because I expect
things to happen immediately.
So there's a language, and
there's a term for this right
now.
Our colleges are calling
it drone parenting.
And it's kind of fascinating,
and it's a little scary
when we think about this.
It's helicopter parenting with
tech-enhanced surveillance
capacity and expanded reach.
So they move from
hover parenting,
hovering, to drone parenting.
At college, what
it looks like is
arguing with profs on behalf
of a grown children for grades.
It may also look like correcting
their paper and turning it in,
and a prof is very
clear that this is not
coming from a student,
but coming from a parent.
And then let's look at what
it looks like in the world
of work, and I can certainly
speak to this is as a parent
of kids that are in
the world of work--
going to job fairs and bosses'
offices in place of grown
children.
And I know for myself-- I
see some heads nodding here.
For myself, when my oldest
son got his first job,
it was amazing for that
job to court my husband
and I equally as they
courted my husband,
with an assumption that
if they wanted him,
we had to talk him into it too.
So I'm seeing a shift
happening culturally that's
looking like it's normal.
And we may not want this to
want to be normal, you guys.
I mean, this one this
one gives us big pause--
so drone parenting.
Now, I also want to
talk about a shift
that we have seen in our five
years of working with kids,
and I'm going to throw
this question out to you.
When we ask kids-- we
show a short video,
and it's very old
school about someone
being digitally tethered
and losing conversation.
And we show them this video,
we asked them who they see.
Who do you imagine they see
when we show this, any guesses?
You nailed it.
Now that's a shift.
They didn't see
their parents before.
They used to see themselves.
And we're now in
fourth grade primarily.
We're in elementary school,
high school, middle school,
and high school.
And the shift I'd say in
the last year and a half
are kids are now
saying, that's my mom.
That's my dad.
That's my family.
And I'm going to take you
into some of the quotes
that we've been hearing
from kids on this one.
This is a ninth grade student.
"If parents stop for a second
to look behind their iPad
and put down the screen,
they would realize their kids
are right in front of them,
and they are trying."
And that's really
pretty intense quote.
We often present this in many
ways in fourth and fifth grade,
and it's amazing.
Kids are shooting
up their hands,
and they're sharing strategies
with each other on how they
can bring their parents back.
And here are some
of the strategies.
One child said, "I see
my dad two days a week,
and he's always on his iPad."
The bottom are the
strategies kids
are sharing with each
other about how they pull
their parents back. "I
shake them, poke them,
pinch them, bribe them, yell
at them, wave a piece of paper
in front of their face,
grab their phone away."
Our newest one that
we heard is "call them
by their full name," which
we thought was hysterical.
"Put my face in their
face until they see me,"
but the one that really
concerns us is "then I give up."
And then they say, and then I
give up, and I go in my room,
and I get on my device.
And what concerns us is
kids in elementary school
still think parents
are incredibly cool,
and they're looking
for connection,
and they're looking for
a time to have that eye
contact and conversation.
But if they're learning early,
at this point, that nobody's
home, they're going
to just drift away.
And they're going
to just go to Google
to look up things and
not go to their parents.
So this is definitely an issue
that we're seeing and paying
attention to.
I also want to talk
about techno perfection.
And when we ask our kids to
define techno perfection,
they're really clear that
it's about a curated image.
It's about trying to be
perfect, and expecting
that perfection is something
they have to have 24/7.
I was amazed, when we
do our advisory groups,
that we asked them
this question,
they could have talked
about it forever.
And we asked them, what are
the acceptable body types?
And they told us that it's
super skinny or Kim Kardashian.
And if you look at the
new Barbie dolls that have
come out, it's interesting.
Has anyone been aware of the
new Barbies that have come out?
Go check them out.
They're fascinating to me.
Some of them are looking
just like Kim Kardashian,
and some of them are looking
just like super skinny.
And so in a way-- and they
thought this was really good
news, because it was
defining real bodies.
But are they real bodies?
So look at what's
going on there.
Our feeling is that
the subliminal message
is beauty is unachievable.
And we're hearing our girls
talk about this quite a bit.
And what we're
also very aware of
is that it's not just
a girl issue, that it
is a boy issue was well.
So what I want to talk
with you about right
now are the kinds of
things that our kids have
said to us in our advisory
group about what they want
their parents to do to help.
How do we change this?
How do we start
this conversation?
And the first thing
they said to us
is, we want our parents to
help us combat those myths,
because to us it's real.
We see a billboard, and we're
assuming that it's real.
Help us understand
that being thin
will not bring you happiness.
I love this one-- "help me
not seek external validation
and find my own voice."
Start this conversation
early, and people are often
very afraid to start
the conversation
because they think
it's too young.
There is no too young.
And shift the
conversation-- what
are they trying to sell you?
There is no middle-schooler
that wants to be manipulated.
And once they realize
someone's trying to sell them
something, especially
an adult, they're
going to be able to push back.
And as I mentioned
earlier, this one
gets them screaming
when we show them
Justin Bieber-- can't
even really explain
what's going on there.
But what I love about
showing this image
is that they're not
supposed to see the one over
in this corner.
They're supposed to see that
really buffed defined one.
And what we want them to
get is the manipulation.
We are seeing that because
it's seen as a female issue,
they're often not
able to discuss it
the way that girls do.
And we want them to, because
that conversation is important.
And we really love
this quote because we
think that pushing
back is what we really
want our kids to be able to do.
I'm looking at our
time, and I want
to talk a bit about
sleep because sleep
is an enormous issue
that's impacting kids.
And at first, on
this slide I used
to have what our teens
are saying about sleep.
But we had to change
this because of our kids.
It's what our children and our
teens are saying about sleep,
and it's been significant.
"I close my eyes to
go to sleep and feel
like my brain is on coffee."
And this just
happened last week.
That was a fifth grade quote.
And I'm curious if anybody
ever feels like their brain's
on coffee in here?
When you go to sleep, it's
like what is going on?
This is emerging
science, and we're
starting to get more
information on this,
and I'll share with you
in brief what we're seeing
and what we're learning.
But we are seeing that our
kids are coming to school
with digital hangovers.
And I can certainly
see that adults
are going to work with
digital hangovers as well.
What we are finding
out is that kids
between the ages of 9
and 15 are especially
sensitive to light
exposure in the evening.
Light comes at
them from any way,
and they're sensitive
to all light.
But we're also
wondering, and we're
learning that the blue light
emitted from digital devices
may be particularly impactful.
And we know it's
impactful to us as well.
The more evening light
exposure, the lower
that level of melatonin.
It's true for all of
us, and incredibly true
for this age group.
So it suppresses their
body's time clock
and makes them fall
asleep later and therefore
wake up with those
digital hangovers.
So what do we do about this?
And I want to say what do "we"
do about this, because this
impacts all of us.
And these are just a
few things to look at.
Is anyone using Flux?
It's a great one.
And the new iPhone
has Night Shift,
which is going to
be also mirroring--
we know that blue light tricks
our brain into staying awake.
So Flux does this amazing
thing, which is so important,
it mirrors our
body's time clock.
It mirrors what our body needs.
When it's nighttime, it
turns that reddish glow
of the sun setting.
When it's daytime,
it turns blue.
And there are also really
good apps that we recommend.
SelfControl is one of
them that blocks access
to distracting websites.
StayFocused is another
that sets a timer where
you can block your own
access to those websites.
And Readability
is one that really
helps with online clutter.
It's amazing we're
having to develop
these tools to help us not get
distracted, but we have to.
And we have to really support
our kids at doing this as well.
And then finally, when
Erica and I are in schools
and we're really
challenging parents,
we're encouraging them to
change the norms around 24/7
connectivity, because
we're all feeling it.
So what are the
skills our kids are
going to need in the future?
We know that it's
the ability to work
cooperatively and
collaboratively
through network communication.
We see it.
We're living it right here--
collective intelligence,
crowdsourcing.
And it's that very
sharing, tweeting, constant
updating that's preparing
them to do that work.
I mean, it's that
thing that worries us,
that is so incredibly important.
But here's the paradox,
and here's the piece
that we have to look at.
With the world at
their fingertips,
it's the ability to tune out
the noise-- because there's
an awful lot of
noise out there--
and engage in technology with
awareness and balance that's
going to cause us to be able
to succeed in this world.
So that's the piece that's
so incredibly important.
And I want to share with you
that we are really at a place
right now, after working
with 14,000 kids,
and we're moving very,
very quickly and expanding,
we're looking for
partners, and we
are looking to expand our
reach to organizations
and to schools, particularly
where kids can't afford this.
And we feel that
everybody needs it.
We want to introduce our
executive director, Mia Walker,
who is a former Googler.
And we will be here
for a conversation
and really look forward
to talking with you,
if you have any strategies
and ideas about this.
Thank you so very
much for coming.
Thank you for inviting us, Joel.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
Thank you, guys.
How do you define
acceptable usage of a phone?
And the question came in
two parts, and I love it,
so I'll read them out verbatim.
One is, is it OK to take
away phones for bad grades?
And as a follow
on, is a different
when with they or we use the
phone just to research things,
like, oh, let me Google
that-- to pick up the phone
and check it out,
that kind of thing?
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET:
I want to say something
about taking the phone
away for bad grades.
The danger of doing that is
creating the forbidden fruit.
I mean, if we take it
away as a punishment,
if you really want to
make someone fall in love
with something, make
it the forbidden fruit.
And I think that that technique
is just is doomed for failure.
Personally, as a
parent, I don't think
that that works very well.
That said, there is an
absolute need for limits,
and our kids desperately
need our limits.
Do you have any other
thoughts on that?
ERICA PELAVIN: Yeah, I
thinking the same thing.
And that sometimes being part
of a conversation ahead of time,
some preventive work--
talking about a contract
or pointing out you're noticing
that their grades are slipping
or that they're
acting inappropriately
in their conversation
is a better way
to talk about it than just
grabbing the device away.
Because we will often
hear kids say, oh,
I just get a free account and
use my friend's phone to text.
Or I have a dummy phone
that I give my parents,
and they don't remember.
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET: I also
like kids to really understand
that our bodies are
not meant to multitask,
that we don't do it very
well, that our bodies are
in desperate need of sleep.
And none of us do this well.
I think that parents
have to model this.
I think that if we just
direct kids-- what we're also
hearing from kids is
parents will say to them,
get rid of that device.
And as they're saying that,
they're on their device.
And so that will not bode well.
They're really watching
our behavior far more
than they're listening to us.
So we have to really
be willing to model it.
And that may mean, and some
families are doing this,
it's 10 o'clock.
All devices are down,
including ours-- not easy.
But that is effective.
ERICA PELAVIN: In
my house, we have
forced family fun, where all the
devices have to stay at home,
and we all leave.
Just really carving out
those digital free spaces
where kids feel
like-- or families
are feeling like
we're being heard
and that they're important.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Yes, it's
a great idea for everyone
to put their phones
down at 10:00 PM.
But how do you reconcile
that with the need for kids
to stay in touch instantly with
their friends, who don't put
their phones down at 10:00 PM.
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET:
You know, we're
in an interesting
time right now.
And I think, as parents, we
have to come together and work
as communities.
That is not easy to do, and
yet it's so important to do.
I mean, I think we
have to model it.
I also think it would be so
great to have a community
conversation and have
other parents doing it too.
But I remember as a
parent being told,
you're the only mom doing
this, and I'm so angry at you
for doing it.
And it's OK to have that anger,
because we're really helping
them out of a jam.
What kids say to
us privately, they
don't want to share it with
parents but, "I am exhausted,
and I want off that group text.
But I can't tell them.
But I'm going to let you know.
And I'm not going
to tell my parents."
But you're helping
them out of a jam.
So I'm encouraging
parents to set limits.
ERICA PELAVIN: I'm kind
of agreeing with Gloria.
I've been called the Meanest
Mom NA-- in North America--
because I wouldn't let phones
come to a sleep over because I
kind of feel, as my parents
did, that nothing good happens
after 11 o'clock when
you're in a group,
that it just kind of goes south.
But my experience has been that
we do a super good job finding
out the best tutors, the
best schools, the best
camps, talking to parents all
the time to gather information.
And that if we could
use that same curiosity
and connectedness to
say, hey, you guys,
do you remember when
our parents wouldn't
let us call after 9
o'clock because it was rude
or answer the phone
during dinner?
And it was just an "is," right?
And so I think the more we talk
to other parents and our kids'
friends groups or to help
them do what Gloria said
and realize, like we're
not doing it to be mean.
We're doing it because these
devices are tricking your brain
into believing it's
daytime, and you don't
feel good and getting at that.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: How
many kids actually
want to fight distractions,
from this question, when
I was a teen, I
didn't really notice
when I was tired or distracted.
And I didn't think
getting A's instead
of B's was worth the
extra work anyway.
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET: No kid
wants to fight distraction.
I mean, they're not
even feeling distracted.
I hope I'm hearing
this correctly.
No child would say to you--
they would all say to you,
I am amazing at multitasking.
I could do 20 things at once.
I can do whatever.
I mean, but we all
said that too, right?
I mean, I said I could
do whatever at any time.
Because that ability
to recognize that they
can't, isn't there yet.
So we have to be the ones
to say, you know what?
I'm going to help you with this.
It's really not
about getting As.
It's more about staying
healthy and safe.
I mean we can't survive
on three hours of sleep,
and I know some kids
that are trying.
We've heard teachers say
that papers are coming in
at 11:30, 12:30
for fifth graders,
because they're
getting so distracted.
That's not working for anybody.
ERICA PELAVIN: We have
to get their pain point.
And right now, what we're
noticing in the classroom
is group texts are a
pain point-- that they
go on to several group
texts, and then hundreds
of [INAUDIBLE]
what's happening just
flood their inbox and
the bings and make
it hard to go to sleep.
So I put it back on them, like
what can we do about this?
What do you guys
think you can do?
And they come up with
amazing strategies.
So putting it back into
their hands to help
and hitting their pain
point really works.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
That's a great segue
to the question I
had for you guys,
which is, do you know of or
organize or anything groups
or meet ups for
discussions among parents
or between parents and
kids or even among kids
with your advisory
panel or anything,
where people can go in and share
and develop their solutions?
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET:
I love that question.
We're seeing that
popping up all over.
So we're seeing schools, and
when we go to a community
and we present to
schools, we're seeing
parents afterwards going,
we're going to start something.
And we need to start it now.
And they come
together as parents,
no differently than we came
together around other issues,
as an opportunity to discuss.
Some of our most
effective work has
been working with parents
separately and kids separately,
and then bringing
everybody together
to share strategies with
each other-- really powerful.
So often it starts small.
It's often parents
going, I'm lost,
and then coming together
other parents who equally
feel that way, and
then just starting
that community conversation.
ERICA PELAVIN: I love
what you're talking about,
because we spend most
of our time talking
about facilitating conversations
about how it feels.
And I love the idea, as we start
to expand our program bigger,
to talk about what
can we do about it?
How do we work as a
collective community
to create a kinder internet,
where we have incredible power
and we can do great things?
And I would just love people
to come to us with ideas
and to help these kids
facilitate their own--
GLORIA MOSKOWITZ-SWEET:
So, Joel,
I wanted to say something
about our conversation
after we met you.
I'm fired up about
parents before they
have children saying, we
want to do something now
because we're concerned.
And some of the
current research--
that the new research that's
coming out around attachment
is a little scary.
So we are encouraging
parents to talk,
even before they have
kids, about how they
want to deal with this world.
So this conversation is
incredibly important.
JOEL KALMANOWICZ: Well,
thank you both very much.
We're just about out of time.
I really appreciate you
guys coming down to Google
to give us all a talk.
Thank you.